laughs
there's been a shift in the landscape of
Comedy first I was told to shut up
because I would never understand then I
was told that silence was violence
you wanna call me right wing you want to
call me a conservative I'm a proud
conservative
somebody comes up here and goes you're
Politically Incorrect and I go you don't
read Chomsky do you
[Music]
right-wing fanatic but there are certain
things I'm willing to fight for
welcome to murderer's Road airing Monday
September 4th 10 a.m Eastern for the
very first time
whatever happened to communicability
have you seen the freaking flame
wrecking fight like that with familiar
friends
[Music]
but you just can't take all these leaves
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at louder with
kreider.com gain access to an unrivaled
catalog of unapologetic and entertaining
Traders including the Hodge twins Nick
depalo Brian Callan and of course Alex
Jones all that and everything you see
today is entirely funded by viewers like
you for 89 annually join the fight at
Lotto with credit.com mug club today
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
delicious uh glad to be with you today
actually for the first time we are going
to be trying this rundown of what we'll
be discussing the show hit it we have
the uh oh there you go the entertainment
minutes today I don't know if you know
this but the five late night hosts
often referred to as failures uh are
going to be teaming up for a show uh
also Tucker Carlson predicted a war with
China uh because they've you know
annexed Russia Russia sorry a war with
well proc with both of them well yes
eventually both of them and we have
exclusive audio of the first call
between XI xingping and uh Vladimir
Putin and then also something that
people are talking about and I want to
be clear here
um and I'd like for you to comment below
uh Mitch McConnell look it's it's sad
it's also sad what they've done with
with former Vice President Joe Biden now
I think of course that these people have
been bad actors in a lot of ways but I'm
not nearly as upset with them as I am
with the people pulling the strings
these people these are they're senile a
lot of these people this is elder abuse
and I don't know if you know this it's a
big problem in this country elder abuse
takes place at a much higher rate than
young people when you're talking about
old folks homes when you're talking
about financial fraud identity theft it
happens a lot and sending people out
there
when they are completely unaware of
their surroundings uh I think it's a
relevant topic especially when we get
into I said especially let me ask you a
question especially especially when we
get into how many of our Representatives
um defy the actuary tables they should
be dead
the average age is the same as the
average age of a of a leatherback turtle
okay so we'll be talking about that and
I know that sometimes you may get sad
when you see old people but you know
what it's also funny yes so uh
I had another question of the day do you
think that former Vice President Biden
would start a war with Russia just to
stay in power do you think that's
something that he would do we have a lot
to get to uh number two Gerald Morgan
geralda how are you I'm doing well you
called me by my real name I know I know
it's jail day that was a slip what's the
matter with G Morgan Jr well because now
we just mug Club just got certified gold
on the Twitter oh that's right and so
everyone here will get those gold badges
which I don't know if it means anything
badges yeah we don't need no stinking
badges that's a horrible start and when
you hear this
you know who it is he's gonna be the
King Center in Melbourne Florida that's
the one in Stateside not the penal
colony September 23rd I didn't go see
all of his tour dates by the way in your
neck of the woods briancallen.com and
that's a great way for you to support if
you don't join mug Club look live ticket
sales hey it's something you can go and
do and go support these folks uh the
live ticket sales don't lie Brian Callan
good to be here and I'm always brimming
with comments and I have to the hardest
part of the show is for me to keep quiet
before you introduce me yeah yeah but uh
my comments are still if that's your
most difficult struggle you've lived a
pretty full life thank you buddy what
comments do you have I haven't heard one
oh God they're still Brewing he wrote on
my notepad yeah
he wrote big dates in September big
dates repeatedly you're not supposed to
check my notepad yeah do whatever I want
on that notepad no you won't other
things happen you won't there's a reason
for weight classes all right
so I don't know if you know this hi the
joke is you'll live forever okay but I'm
a little insecure about my Frailty
around I'll die very young I'm 170
American pounds 173 actually after I've
eaten wow okay yeah I know but still
live I still got it still Supple and you
know that hey we're only five minutes
into the show sorry buddy so
Hollywood writer strike and it's still
going on uh and the late night hosts
have a real problem because they have
other people who write almost all of
their materials really yes uh like 40
writers depending on the place you know
hundreds and hundreds of employees who
simply actually create the content uh
and then they have to pre-tape it and
then still Whittle it down or if you're
like Chelsea Handler Whittle it down
even more and steal your guests jokes
before they go on air and have them
submit it it's true I don't know if you
guys know that it's funny now hold on
I've done that so that brings us
that's true you did it's not really a
joke more of a statement I never had
that experience with her yeah I know
sticking up for her good for you who
cares
this week's entertainment minute
[Music]
so the late night hosts yes I just said
that phrase in the year 2023. dropped a
trailer I guess for their new and here's
the thing remember when trailers used to
be you know in the 90s you have like
fatal attractions there's always a
cliffhanger and it told you about the
film then we went through the era of the
Michael Bay trailers where it was just a
bunch of Transformers effects and then
Transformer sound effects made it into
trailers that had nothing to do with
robots
um like what is this this is The Hunger
Games
okay now trailers can just mean some uh
aging Old-Timers in a in a webcam so
here is now the new podcast where uh
they've formed the the Megazord I guess
of late night hosts uh Strike Force Five
they're calling it and I warn you wow I
mean you have to watch it through your
fingers Strike Force Five One More Time
Jimmy yeah hi I'm Jimmy Fallon I'm
Stephen Colbert
I thought when you said Jimmy you meant
me Jimmy but you meant Jimmy Jimmy I
always mean you but when you always be
at Myers who do you mean I mean John
Oliver it's the five of us together for
uh maybe an hour a day Strike Force Five
is the name of our podcast subscribe to
it now Spotify or wherever else you get
your podcasts
but Spotify you watching it was so
depressing it put me in such a funk I
had to cheer myself up with The Lovely
Bones dream for life
I have to be polite
be polite
that's another rule well not more
chipper there we go yeah
was that the full Stinger
what other podcast yeah that's the full
teaser
what subjects do they touch on well the
beauty is when you're that funny when
you're that town you could just talk
about anything we're just gonna we're
gonna sit down talk for me
maybe an hour maybe hey you know 20
million dollars couldn't you do better
than maybe hey guys okay guys we have
two jimmies let's do a joke or the the
wrong one respond
you said Jimmy I'm Jimmy Fallon
no no no no no he's Kimble I'm falling
[Laughter]
at the end it'll be great
looks like these guys are I just I miss
the ghost of Johnny Carson you guys are
really big putts
somebody needs so according to CBS news
I guess they're the central Mainframe
here uh five of America's most famous
late night comedy hosts are banding
together to create a podcast to discuss
the ins and outs of the ongoing
Hollywood strikes sounds fascinating I
was going to say even the topic even the
top this is how out of touch they are by
the way murderers Roe is coming up we
weren't planning on plugging this again
here it's coming up a Monday on Labor
Day because we don't pick your pocket
every first Monday of September but
we're not going to be discussing the
Hollywood strike oh God I'd rather go
through a car wash without my car yes
it's called a shower Brian
and then you'll never guess what
happened after that they stonewalled us
yeah what why tune in tomorrow though we
have more information yeah we're going
to be discussing exclusively the
Hollywood writers strike because we
think that that strikes at the heart of
what affects most Americans who don't
watch our show
for an hour a day yeah yeah now the
trailer it was dropped on Jimmy Fallon's
uh X page you know because it's not
Twitter anymore it's gonna take a minute
and remember they protested when Elon
bought it what it was like all back in
the day they used to say if if so-and-so
wins the election they did it with
George W bush they said with Romney they
did it don't I'll move to Canada yeah
and they never did oh yeah if this
happened to Elon Musk I'm leaving X I
notice you still have your verification
badge interesting
California
should make a
stand the reactions are pretty much what
you would expect this is from some
Twitter profiles one guy uh wrote guys
if we combine all our viewership we'll
get at least 15 maybe even 16 people
to watch that's ambitious
funny one was someone said oh good so I
can ignore you all at once instead of
individually
you're like yeah that guy hey I bet
actually he's not on strike no okay he's
not union
scale
thanks Jimmy
hey he's talking about his weight again
yeah
Brian Kelly
sometimes that's my name
is coach I hate that we're talking about
them so here's the thing this is
something you guys need to know uh the
18 to 49 demo the coveted demo yeah they
do not tune in they do not tune into
late night programs anymore the numbers
are abysmal regardless of the writer's
strike and this is just I don't know if
this I think this is a total average not
the demo average from March you guys can
correct me Fallon is down to 1.4 million
this is not the demo this is not the
demo numbers yeah Colbert is down to 1.4
million Kimmel's down to 1.6 wow this is
total this is total oh and they put in
there oh crap you mean Crowders almost 3
million
around up to three million okay that's
that I did not this is it just so you
know someone added this without me
knowing it's not a prompter I don't care
but the demo numbers there are a couple
hundred thousand just to be clear wow no
one aged 18 to 45 some people do it ages
21 to 50 something they're not tuning in
to late night no and these people are
declawed back and this is the Silver
Lining here remember these people with
influence elections a lot at one point
in time take this from and I get it the
industry has changed Carson right you're
talking about 30 million these are now
today's Super Bowl numbers you'll never
have that again there are three networks
and once they went out there was an
Indian going beep so I understand that
we're not going back to that but this
has gotten significantly worse before
the writers strike and so now they've
teamed up by the power of yours combined
I suck yeah what happens is yeah
podcasts and shows like this have
exposed Hollywood because what happened
if you look at uh Spotify people like
Prince Harry and Meghan Markle and they
had you know Springsteen and Obama doing
a podcast nobody tuned in and what
happens is they went oh you guys aren't
that interesting in long-form discussion
you're great in five minute Clips we
have a moratorium on even mentioning
Bruce Springsteen in the studio I I
there are a few people
sack of talentless well hold on now
he's a bit of a Springsteen fan over
here but you shouldn't be but you know
what I mean okay
by the way we used to I don't know if we
have this one of the first shows I ever
did on Reddit today we're going to be a
little more relaxed one of the first
shows I ever did back uh back on uh when
it was on radio is syndicated I don't
know if you were on that show first
guess I think were Monica Crowley and
Chael son and and Kayla Harrison an
Olympic medalist I remember that show
like it was yesterday or maybe I'm blind
maybe I don't remember
uh early on
um back then we pulled up an old clip of
Bruce Springsteen you know no it's just
I hope you all been good this year not
too many in back then he was sitting
there talking like this when we do rock
and roll ah like a young Al Pacino it's
totally fake yep and you know
figuratively it would be nice of all the
people that trigger you Bruce
Springsteen because I'm offended by
media pull up the Santa Claus is Coming
to Town performance by Bruce Springsteen
I know it's very referencing it is
horrifically bad you know what guys you
can comment I don't want to get into a
whole Springsteen thing we did this at
run through it's enough also John Cougar
Mellencamp he can take a long walk off a
short painter and Chad Diane's a great
song guys I don't care you say adding to
Hollywood's idiocracy we're living in
Real Time Warner Brothers now announced
uh and I again there's X it's not
Twitter it's not HBO it's Max this
should tell you how a lot of these
companies you know the these entities
aren't necessarily working they cannot
apply their classic cost structure to
New Media and unfortunately they have
the burden of these unions who do serve
some purpose I actually agree with them
on the AI issues because this is
something that could put a lot of people
out of work these are skilled jobs and
no no but also your rights your rights
as a human being where someone can just
mimic it with a like I understand that's
not ill-founded but that's not all they
want they always want more money and the
unions look out for their unions I mean
I was in the actors Union because I had
to be I had to pay twenty twenty five
hundred dollars before ever showing up
on set and the first rule had gotten in
the United States even though I was
already technically a member because I
was a member in Canada they said yeah it
is but you have to pay this fee I said
we'll just take it out of the first
couple of episodes I said no you have to
pay it up front and actually true story
My Brother who was one of the first
YouTube partners in 2006 lent me the
money so that I could fulfill a role
that I had already received anyways I
think a lot of it also comes down to the
fact that you if as a writer or an actor
you got to be very careful about how
much you think you're actually worth one
thing as an actor in Hollywood I always
knew whether it was writing or acting is
I was always eminently replaceable yes
it's just the way it is man I mean you
know it's just too easy to be like next
yeah and plus it's a the cottage
industry Brian uh Brian count
look-alikes
so CNN Live alerts just they think this
is going to help them HBO became Max
right buying Discovery in history I
particularly love their historical
accuracy on the mermaid yeah so it's now
Max and now they decided oh this isn't
working let's add CNN Live alert pop-ups
that means during other shows or films
that you are watching on Max you may get
a CNN pop-up and by the way I'm part of
the beta testing and saw one of these
last night uh again while tearing myself
up watching The Lovely Bones I'm not
gonna hurt you Susie
yeah
this is CNN breaking news
[Music]
[Laughter]
I don't even try watching Schindler's
List it's very difficult don't you
always wonder what like in the meeting
in the idea room in the war room where
they get what would you guys are ratings
are what and then somebody went how
about pop-ups genius yes you mean in
movies that people pay for to not have
universals Moses throw in like a
commercial right Leah decided the
promised land with pop-ups this is going
to save our Network yeah I'll tell you
one time I was at Fox News and they were
looking at doing this new show and it
was an ensemble and it wasn't working
and one of the people there who was
ancient who had worked on like the Steve
Allen Show uh he suggested a monkey
no oh boy he goes just have a monkey
there's all my any like you'd be there
like the whole time
like on a perch I'm like I don't know if
monkeys use perches I don't know but I
don't think
he want a monkey for what just likes to
be there because right because people
love monkeys just a just a monkey Prime
yeah that's uh that's a little bit of
genius and by the way monkeys are always
funny there was a knock down drag out
fight Mad TV my first year we were in
The Writer's room it was the I've never
seen anything like it was an absolute
brawl over what what word was funnier in
the sketch monkey or and I was
like boy yeah well probably we're
all canceled we're all canceled oh come
on it's a real word no that's right we
should call them dwarves because that's
less offensive why did they decide
was I don't know I just go with
Willow and by the way CNN plus was a 100
million dollar Venture shut down after a
month yeah 100 million dollars couldn't
make it work but hey the failed hundred
million dollar Venture let's put their
pop-ups into max you comment if you
think Hollywood's ever going to get it
right of course I can guess that's been
this week's entertainment minute
all right you know what I think we're
going to I know there's an update on
Hurricane uh Dahlia let's let's put that
to later right now because I think
that's a lot of stuff yeah we have some
other stuff to get to and by the way
it's a live show Monday through Friday
10 a.m Eastern here on Rumble if you're
watching if you're watching on YouTube
we're testing the algorithm please do
hit that like button because we've been
Shadow throttled there uh of course I
recommend uh you head over to rumble
anyway and we'll be continuing doing the
mug Club segment um segment it's a whole
other show every day it did it is it
really is okay so let's get to Gerald
knows things here I don't know if we
understand for this but it's about
Tucker don't worry I know I just messed
up your whole life I'm fine your map
um Tucker Carlson obviously talked about
uh I think was it yesterday that he
mention this yeah I think it was well at
least I saw the interview come out
yesterday so maybe it was from before
but the clip started circulating around
the internet okay so he uh predicted war
with uh China and uh and and Russia and
um well look we'll look I'm not huge on
geopolitics
and I don't like the Russians or the
Chinese either one you're the modest
yeah that's true I don't like the people
that brings us to Gerald nose thing
all right so Tucker was talking with
Adam Carolla and uh he he predicted that
in this this may sound a little bit far
out but if you follow through on this
logic it actually makes a little bit of
sense it's in the realm of possibility
this is kind of like an Alex Jones
moment we predicted this when the war
with Ukraine started no no no we didn't
predict that he would start a war to
stay in power oh no not by no no so we
predicted that uh obviously there it
would unfortunately kind of force Russia
into the arms of the tiny arms well it's
gonna force him into the eyes of China
but really his point right now is that
we are technically kind of in a cold war
State because we're funding the enemy of
Russia so this is specific to Russia
he's saying within a year we're going to
be drawn into a hot war with Russia
right here in the clip so they can't
lose they will do anything to win so how
do they do that they're not going to do
covet again I know everyone the rights
are afraid they're going to do covet and
mask man they're not going to do that
they can't do that if they've already
been exposed that won't work there's
going to be no what are they going to do
they're going to go to war with Russia
is what they're gonna do
there will be a hot war between the
United States and Russia in the next
year
yes of course they want it anyway
um I don't think we'll win it but that's
a separate analysis but I think it's a
political matter they need to declare
war footing in order to assume War
Powers in order to win I believe that
and I think the evidence suggests that's
true what do you think is wrong there
Gerald I think the wrong we'd win I
think there's no real winning a war like
that today though I think is what I
think I think these are unwinnable well
he didn't say that so he didn't say like
nobody wins he said and we won't win you
know yeah I mean the Russian military is
a joke now it is a joke nukes we have we
have them I think they have maybe they
have slightly more we have slightly more
I can't remember we're the top two
obviously in the world and we have lots
and lots and lots and lots of nukes yes
I get that I don't think that we go to a
nuclear war but his point is that if the
Biden Administration has no other
options and they get us into a war and
declare and he he said you know kind of
the War Powers Act and making sure that
the party in power stays in power and
that situation so there is no election
yeah if they can't get Donald Trump one
of these ways this is a way for them to
stay in power and I again I think this
is a little out there for me I don't
necessarily agree that that's going to
happen I don't think it's out there to
to make the statement that
administrations understand that a
Perpetual state of war is often good but
to stay in power that's a different
thing I don't think I mean I don't know
in other words it's a very clear and you
guys can comment I'll be interested to
hear uh the discussion or read the
discussion in the comments section
sometimes I have it I have it read to me
in one of those AI voices
but it is interesting to think okay
there's a path there's a straight path
with the lockdowns with the mandates how
that affects the election we know that
that happened right and I don't think
that they will accomplish it I hope not
I know there are plenty of people who
are willing to be uh you know useful
pawns and we'll get into the abuse of
the elderly in a little bit as well but
um I don't see the direct path and it
doesn't mean that it couldn't happen
with a war with Russia the direct path
into affecting the election in other
words if you're saying hey we believe
that maybe it'll increase his popularity
because you'll be able to sort of
project a pseudo-patriotism and vilify
you know this foreign enemy yeah but
there's a very clear set there's a very
clear rule set with covid mandates on
how you win an election by abusing that
with absentee ballots and things like
that right yeah so Tucker's point is
since it's already happened it probably
won't happen again because we're a
little bit we're more aware of that kind
of thing but don't you think it's way
easier both are hard but it would seem
to be way easier to instill mandates or
lockdowns than starting a hot war with a
nuclear power like Russia I think
they're I don't know how we'd start I
think they're both easy to do I think
it's a tougher sell in as far as a
straight path to winning an election
that's my thought but you would need you
would need somehow for I think Russia to
invade a NATO power like the Poland you
don't no all you need all you need is
for it to appear is though Russia
invaded a nuclear power I'm sorry a NATO
power like Poland that's it all you need
is somebody to do something that you can
make hey they they did this and that's
pretty easy I mean those those Pollocks
are surely you just say hey I think I
see some Russians over there what what
the hell
and they're like ah there we go now
let's pop off some nukes yeah so we'll
see I don't know but you've been hearing
this by the way for a very long time uh
the threat of the Russia China Alliance
and we've talked about that as well so
this is not new but here's a refresher
U.S officials have been closely
monitoring signs of increased
cooperation between Beijing and Moscow
as you know uh would China and Russia
form an alliance against the U.S do you
think that's a realistic possibility
Putin met in Beijing where they signed
the joint declaration promising each
other uh a partnership without any
limits you conveniently left out the
most important part of the deal which is
what the United States wins out of it
that would only be conditioned on
Vladimir Putin exiting his military
alliance with China and just to be clear
as far as an update that matters uh the
Chinese just Incorporated a Russian
Island into their territory on a new map
now I don't know if that's a Mappo
that's a power move right there it's
like that's ours and sometimes you know
we have our investigative journalism but
a lot of people don't realize we also
have you know we have exclusives that
are given to us across the globe on a
regular basis we have an exclusive
leaked phone call of uh shishing Peng
Putin which may have been what led to
the current state of affairs
call him
okay
we have common enemy and you want an
alliance
Alliance
one more time
no rest sir we Russia is strong never
mind
God
this is freaking huh
[Applause]
that's it that sounds very heated I'm
not intimidated well that's how you lose
an island right there they're not very
unified they can't get along they're not
very unified uh don't hang up this has
been Gerald no stuff
all right so
[Laughter]
um I want to discuss the Mitch McConnell
the stroke yeah some people are calling
it broke which doesn't really work it
doesn't roll off the timer
come on guys come on hey everyone let's
be tasteful yes there's nothing funny
about any of this now I will say this
this is sad of course but it's something
that's lost I think in a lot of people
it's easy to sort of make fun of Mitch
McConnell or former Vice President Joe
Biden but we do have this is the the
median demographic uh the median age I
should say of our political leadership
um it's the only place where the median
age is older than the Fox News
viewership that's yeah it's rare and
this does matter because they're
actually I mean it's a marvelous or
they're a miracle as far as defying
actuary tables but a lot of these people
as well they're being abused you do have
to ask yourself if a former Vice
President Biden doesn't know where he is
well who's running the show if you see
the handlers and how they handle Mitch
McConnell I'm not nearly as mad with
Mitch McConnell I would have been in his
younger days
I'm mad at the handlers popping their
head in where it almost looks like a
choreographed sketch it's so
embarrassing so our politicians are
Representatives they're aging out of
this job and by that I mean they already
shouldn't have these jobs and that
brings us to our newest uh segment the
Silver Alert
foreign
and Colbert couldn't do that because
that's a gross violation of the FCC to
use that warning sound but we're online
put me in contempt now also useful
for Halloween yes it is yesterday uh if
you didn't see this Mitch McConnell had
another deer in a headlight uh moment
and again it said I'm mad with the
people around him and and comment below
if that's that's kind of your gut
instinct uh here you go if you haven't
seen it
what are my thoughts about what running
for re-election in 2026.
oh sure
here's a question Senator running for
re-election that's like a sketch yeah
yeah but he's just he
Ard I'm sorry we're gonna need a minute
shouldn't be there any yep
[Music]
we're gonna need a minute you
mispronounced Eon it should be noted
that McConnell by the way is 81 years
old which is old for a tortoise
what did you expect I know would any of
you would any of you thrust an 82 year
old or a 90 year old into the public
Spotlight with what is meant to be a
high stress job that requires executive
functioning yeah if they're hot I fee
stop it I'm sorry I feel like he
answered the question though yeah how do
you feel about running for re-election
yes yeah and by the way this is this is
think about it he felt that he fell down
or there were rumors that he fell down
earlier this year
um and then there was another moment
caught on camera again it's sad but the
point is this is this doesn't exist in a
vacuum this is Mitch McConnell in July
[Music]
many strokes yeah
I know a lot about uh medical things and
stuff
wait a minute
okay Mitch
anything else you want to say I'm sure
let's go back to you yep that's terrible
that's sad
but the people who are still forcing him
to run for real are evil why are they
doing that they're evil is it because
he's a show-in is that what it is it's
because he's a shell yeah he's a shell
he's a he's a he's an empty suit and
they're the ones you think that former
Vice President Biden is the one pulling
the strings yeah for crying out loud I
mean the guy you can say whatever you
want about the guy the guy was never a
far left woke he was a politician he was
an idiot the guy would and I don't just
mean he would lie he would make up
stories that never happened with people
he never met in places that don't even
exist okay that's when he was young and
now he doesn't he's not sharp enough to
do that so it just comes out as
embarrassing the people who are pulling
the strings are the ones who are evil
but let's go through this really quickly
this is not just some kind of an outlier
and when they say that oh look at uh
vivec would be the he's the youngest
candidate well he's in his late 30s I
mean I'm not saying that he's old but
certainly not young when you're talking
about this and if you look at the
average age of politicians you're
looking well into the 60s Depend and
then certain States into the 70s let me
give you the the the the most prominent
examples Dianne Feinstein right senator
from California 90 years old
are you glad to be back Senator what
have you heard what have I heard about
what about your return how have they
felt about you no I haven't been gone
okay
um you should follow me I haven't been
gone I've been working you've been
working from home is what you're saying
oh I've been here
um I've been voting jobs please
well if you don't know now you
[Music]
[Laughter]
please either no or don't know yeah yes
those are the two options and her dad by
the way got a power of attorney to
manage her Affairs so effectively you
have Britney Spears who's still a
full-fledged voting senator
look she's got a line yeah like you got
to step down well if if somebody has
power of attorney to manage your Affairs
now I know you can get power of attorney
to like in worst case scenario if
somebody has you know maybe that chance
of a stroke or something like that
happen you can do it in advance but this
is not an advance this is something that
we can see happening right in front of
us you can't be the person making big
decisions for your constituents and
ultimately for the American people as a
whole it just can't be done well let's
go on to another favorite uh 83 year old
congresswoman from California Nancy
Pelosi ten States as I said on Friday I
started there early for voting the the
day that we launched Ruth Bader Ginsburg
but to be clear you're not taking any
arrows out of your quiver you're not
ruling anything out
good morning Sunday morning
yes
okay all right all right there are no
arrows left in my quiver do you like
turtles good morning
83 years old her date her LinkedIn
Lister is a Avid Drinker and stock
market Guru
because she's still got some Pluckers
has her husband ever made a stock
purchase of sale based on information
you proceed from you no
absolutely not basically
hold on I want to play that uh clip we
don't have our body language expert in
but that's what's known as the melting
candle power pose when she answers play
it uh over the course of your career has
her husband ever made a stock purchase
of sale based on yeah that's a crazy
person okay we got it by the way uh
she's fallen on tough times though she
has been named the new face of Bud Light
I'm gonna say oh boy it's not a bad ad
no
are those are those uh digitally
enhanced or is that no the bud light's
real okay
I was checking you said at least I'm
thirsty
yeah
Rosa delauro another uh she's 80 years
and uh and a congresswoman from
Connecticut you've been in this role for
oh and Hot Topic you're seeking another
term what is it as you look ahead that
you say I need to stay in this role the
voters need me here don't take no for an
answer and never give up and I live by
this it's a real person sometimes you
should take no for an answer the Hot
Topic employee works on commission Rosa
by the way before she was representative
I knew that I'd seen her before
yep
a spitting image then we have another
one and again all of the references are
available at ladderwithcredit.com this
is not normal
this is well past the age of retirement
now we have another uh 80 year old
Frederica Wilson I was gonna say
Wilkinson who was thinking of Tom
Wilkinson great actor underrated
Frederica Wilson a congress a
congresswoman from Florida with one of
her signature hats congresswoman good
morning great to see you good morning
morning I can barely hear you maybe
that's because of a hair helmet glued to
your head that's the kind of outfit that
you would never that's the kind of
outfit that makes horses rear yes when
was the last time you saw that in the
street just someone you'd be like that's
a crate that's a crazy person if you're
on if you're on a horse the horse you
got to turn your horse around yes it's
gonna spook and your dog's gonna bark
yeah if you were walking with your child
like well we're gonna cross that's a
crazy person
I can't hear you female birds will try
to mate with you yes
just not a safe outfit is what I'm
saying that's true and by the way she
the she's older now she should be
retired right she should live off the
money that she made um after quitting
the Obscure 90s rap group that she
formed
with us
sorry
smash the rumble button if you think
that this is better than the late night
fat fab five the Strike Force Five Force
Five strike get it right the strike
force Strike Force because they strike
at you with force can we admonish we
have to admonish Yakuza and toolman why
there's no Rumble button anymore it's a
thumbs up at Rumble Ed Rumble oh okay we
need a bit of admonishment here I think
it's time to admonish that entire crew
over there yep oh somebody was reading
Twitter last night I guess
no hey don't discourage it it's good for
your soul my point is somebody here
wasn't I responded to it like we like to
smash the rumble button
and this brings us to the uh the bell of
the ball uh former Vice President Biden
who is 80 years old and uh look it was
tough to pick a clip
so take your pick here's a montage
America is a nation that can be defined
in a single word
I was going to put him to put
true and international pressure an
estimation of somewhere between 700
billion and a trillion 300 million
billion dollars poor kids are just as
bright and just as tall as white kids
e i g h percent
[Laughter]
God Save the Queen man
and now of course he's 80 years old and
he's a child care Enthusiast sorry he's
a child Enthusiast hair Enthusiast um
yeah you know what you want to see my
impression of a liberal watching that
clip those clips he has a stutter yeah
oh you can't be suffered from the
stutter if you guys think that's funny
then that's on you yeah here's here's my
impression of a Joe Biden strategist
watching that can we find an old clip of
Dan Quayle somebody help me yeah Quail
it was it was a it was a comedic Witch
Hunt the same thing with George W bush
that's how you know the media is not
looking out for you of course George Lee
Bush mispronounced nuclear nope nuclear
nuclear it's funny okay but it's not
that big of a deal this man is senile
this man doesn't know where he is that's
how you know but where are the comics
talking about this it's it's it's
incredibly rare and by the way an
honorable mention just what we're
talking about um capabilities of
Representatives and this is how you know
that it's not a meritocracy
people got mad that we made fun of them
but we tried to make fun of him so that
he wouldn't be representative right in
order to avoid
exactly what is happening John fetterman
hey everybody it's John and Giselle as
you can see we hit a little bump on the
campaign Trail
um it was on Friday I just wasn't
feeling very well so I decided you know
what I need to get checked out so I went
to the hospital
will try to blow up our economy that's
on them if they have to
judge on that so and the Eagles
are so much better than Eagles
Mr fetterman yeah you need any help I
need all the help I can get yes
well that last one wasn't necessarily as
it wasn't his fault it wasn't
necessarily his fault well it just makes
sense sometimes God doesn't like the
flag behind people like that oh maybe
that's the case and then George
Zimmerman ran out and punched him
giant man huh yeah well you have you
have to the weight class he gets put
into the Super heavyweight with the
goiters now oh gosh
he's only 54. but again he had a stroke
in May before uh
40 was elected and then he had multiple
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
STD infections in seniors particularly
old folks homes they're up 107 because
Viagra because of Cialis and Viagra
those old broads get around and you and
now you can get uh erect slowly the help
of Technology they get around slowly
turn on
old perverts well what happens is
they're widows that's right they're
widows what do they say who are they
saving it for yep yep hard and wrinkled
I call it hard and wrinkled and it takes
a while to identify the clap
and he died
so this is something and again it's easy
to laugh it's and of course yeah it is
kind of funny but it's also a little bit
sad but when you understand that what is
happening right now in this country with
their representatives it's what's
happening to a lot of seniors across
this country and it is your job we we
this whole meme by the way of okay
Boomer and now gen Z will apply it to
anyone they apply it to Gen X they apply
it to Millennials
um the idea that oh you're old you don't
know anything hold on a second I get
that older people can be out of touch
but they do have something to offer it
used to be considered wisdom but now we
simply throw them throw them away like
refuse ah toss them in a pile or you
know maybe they're useful as an empty
suit as a politician hey you know what
the young folks out there appreciate
appreciate your parents appreciate your
grandparents they're not going to be
around
super
[Music]
no that's that's fair they have a
restraining order potentially against
them that's not true uh what we've
actually looked at was a couple of
politicians that are very old that we
disagree with that we didn't put in this
segment Like Bernie Sanders very old
yeah he was on the Sunday shows and he
sounded very much still the Lucid
communist that he is right so just
because we disagreed with him doesn't
make him out of touch or unable to I
guess serve in in capacity in government
also Donald Trump the guys out there
playing golf like he's walking around
hitting golf shots doing everything
that's normal for somebody who's doing
just fine he's old right but he's
somebody he's still all there his fear
is Revenge yes well yeah he can't wait
he can't wait eventually he'll decline
to a point where he shouldn't serve
either but yeah all that Hate's gonna
burn you up Grandpa it keeps me warm
right well they they hold a little red
done for you a little Red Dawn Swayze I
love Shwayze I'd love that can he do the
lift
not anymore I know he's passed away but
these people hold on to power too so
look at Ruth Bader Ginsburg she was so I
guess into staying in office or I'm
sorry she had pancreatic cancer and she
stayed she did but she stayed past the
point where she could have she could
have stepped down and said you know what
President Obama go ahead and put another
one of me in this chair she didn't she
stayed and that was one of the biggest
gifts I'm not saying her dying I'm
saying that if she's going to leave the
Supreme Court whether it's health
reasons passing away or just resigning
she did it under Trump Administration
and that gave us another seat on the
Supreme well you know what actually and
again my my uh my qualm is not with Ruth
Bader Ginsburg remember they try to do
RBG yeah remember someone pulled up from
Mission Control the uh they tried the
video the video of her exercising like
look how surprised she is I think those
producers didn't know look you've been
in enough film sets you've been in
enough documentary sets when she's
moving around with rubber bands and
dumbbells like okay don't move they put
the dumbbell in her hand like okay class
but
and then action
ah we'll add some music we'll add some
music and a win fan yes it's those
people who I have a serious problem with
and again it's the entertainment it's
the entertainment political big Tech
industrial complex I also think part of
it is just people like this know that if
they quit
um they're gonna die like what's keeping
them alive is that possible sort of that
that grind that job well that's Joe
Paterno that's because they're empty and
they have no purpose we got the video
yeah like your grandkids should be your
purpose but yeah exactly
you know but uh in a lot of cases uh if
they want to suckle at the at the public
T yeah here you go again my problem
isn't with RBG my problem is with the
media who just well first off you have
the entertainment industry who decided
to make this I don't know if this is
from a documentary or this is from the
documentary I think that was on Netflix
I'm not entirely this is her working out
yeah so let me let me get my CNN uh how
Ruth Bader Ginsburg stays yeah I mean
there was a documentary on Netflix about
her then there was a documentary and
there was also a scripted uh film that
came out at the same time they were
really really pushing hard because I
really wanted her to stick around for a
little while because they were afraid of
what could happen with the courts and
then CNN uh deciding to disseminate this
clip knowing entirely that it is false
and the people who were involved on big
Tech Platforms in promoting this kind of
content to trick you into thinking yeah
yeah she's doing great while she was
dying a slow painful death this is what
they showed you I think this is within
the year that she died
there you go is there no audio here huh
oh boy he's pulling her up almost
entirely look at her look at her face I
gotta get my hand in my pants
Brian sorry now let me get it out let me
get it let me get it out of my pants let
me get it out you have soft hands for a
colored
she didn't say that she didn't say that
that was Steven's very good Ruth Gator
Bader Ginsburg he is on an actual plank
look at that very impressive
she's never lifted a dump she's never
lifted a dumbbell a day in her life oh
my God this is propaganda right it's
propaganda just like when I'm not saying
that Ruth Bader Ginsburg was Hitler just
to be clear but I'm saying remember
Adolf Hitler he had done so much meth
and morphine and heroin that is his skin
became paper thin and so that's when
they started putting out propaganda like
mind Fury is more hand season ever and
it would come out and crying crying and
then he would collapse he did yeah that
was from yoga and eating vegetables yeah
he also kept Young by hate yes so anyway
that's just it's just a it's a problem
that I have because I've seen it I've
seen it in the entertainment industry is
this new no to uh American politics
where you have the ancient in there it
used to be older people because they
were wiser but now people who are career
politicians who are staying in well into
their 80 80s and 90s that was not the
norm that was not the norm and the
problem is these are basically lifetime
positions not to mention when you're
talking about politicians hey when we
talk about the swamp her sorry hurricane
I was about to say a hurricane I was
just talking about daily um Anthony
fauci was never elected
no just to be clear the swamp is a bunch
of people who are who are appointed
basically lifetime appointments they
don't even have to go through at least
the one election when they're young and
then just sort of you know rest on their
Laurels right think of the hundreds of
thousands of people you have who serve
as bureaucrats in six fit in high
six-figure paying positions in some
instances for decades who are completely
incompetent something else I should tell
you by the way
it's obviously not that hard of a job
people act as though it's Noble to go
into public to go into uh to Public
Service First off it's a misnomer I
don't necessarily think that it's public
service but if Ruth Bader Ginsburg could
be on the Supreme Court like that if
Nancy Pelosi can like that if Mitch
McConnell like that
where else where else could someone with
those mental faculties perform a
full-time job right you wouldn't want
somebody like that and as a flight a
fight flight traffic controller for
example traffic air traffic you said ah
man flight attendant I wouldn't want one
of them as a stewardess I don't want to
touch their old wrinkled peanut skin
hands
they just yes no it's not about ageism
is listen there there should be term
limits I'm a big fan of term limits and
a lot of cases uh maybe even across the
board at all the positions the Supreme
Court should not be a place where you go
to die either I'm sorry that's just not
how we intended this thing to be it
shouldn't be at the whims of a president
whether you get to serve or not and
continue on the court I get that Joe
Biden's trying to do that by stacking
the court so that the court votes for
him and we I don't know we can end up
with maybe 100 Supreme Court Justices
before it's all over but you should have
some kind of lever that says this person
is no longer fit and you know what it's
brilliant I think we actually do nobody
just nobody ever pulls it there should
be it nobody ever says that yeah I think
that that I don't know how how you would
do what the demarcation line would be
but there's got to be some kind of if
you resemble someone who's well
it's got to be something yeah or or
maybe this would you want that person
performing surgery on you well somebody
that old walked in let's go oh no no
because no one would want anyone
performing I wouldn't want anyone other
than a surgeon I think we should the bar
can be lowered you have them side by
side with the film radio
and then you ask them to repeat the
lines like a speak and spell yeah and if
radio is more mentally competent than
your representative then we throw them
in a gator Trench
a gator trench is a quick way to go
believe it it's not because you get
rolled yeah no no those would be
crocodiles Gators are more skittish oh
is that what it is
so you just die of some kind of a
brain-eating we went over this yesterday
when we were talking about boots
you tried to impress me with your your
Caiman wallet I'm like well it's not
data yeah yeah I know I know which means
it's not a Supple there's a gator farmer
out there like I knew it
[Music]
knew it I'm joining my club all right we
do have to hit on this right now because
this can affect you uh obviously uh
hurricane um Adalia Adalia Adalia I
always doubt I believe it's a dahlia or
is it a dahlia I don't know I don't care
India hurricane uh Florida is uh now
they're they're cleaning up after this
uh hurricane has uh made landfall uh
made landfall yesterday but here's a
clip we have a really good uh retail in
terms of all the counties I think other
than the Big Ben proper uh the Tampa the
problem is the signers just doing the
time board Leon County is is doing well
uh we're still assessing what is all
going on on the ground in the places
that had the the initial impact and so
his emergency response team isn't
probably going to try to get diverse
some of those counties today no they're
they're they're not uh they're not
diverse they're so straight and white I
know yeah well I don't know about the
signer but I don't think that's his
choice I think they're kind of assigned
that and of course uh our thoughts and
prayers for anyone affected out there in
Florida but um we actually have our on
the ground correspondent Mr Thomas
Finnegan for the latest updates oh good
foreign
yeah it's been a while Thomas what do
you have for us here today well it's
been an unusually hot summer and I
wanted to display the effects that it's
had on the on the environment so if you
can see behind me the corn has been
burnt to a crisp by the Heat and Sun
well that's interesting but you're
nowhere near the hurricane uh that's the
story so what are you doing there and
why are you holding a flashlight
well I figured since I'm out here anyway
I could do a parody of that scene from
signs where the alien leg goes into the
corner
yeah but it's day it's day and you're
not a comedian
[Music]
you know what maybe the world needs
Strike Force Five I think we do but
I'm not above acknowledging when I've
shortchanged you he's got to get it
right eventually right I don't know I
don't know why we I don't why do we sign
a 12-year contract I don't know he's a
good negotiator Stephen bad move
negotiator it was way off a lot of
content but in September by the way
we're discussing that we will have the
Hodge twins of course their show is
going to be starting here on mug Club
Brian Callan is going to be starting the
Brian Callan show on mug Club tomorrow
tomorrow that starts tomorrow yeah
September one dude stick to my deadlines
oh wow I didn't realize I thought it was
oh I was thinking of The Hodgetwins date
up
okay yeah
so uh yeah Brian count of course you get
Nick de Paulo already Monday through
Friday Monday through Thursday and by
the way to be clear if you're not a
member of mug Club Nick depalo show is
also all of their shows are still
available like on Apple they're
available uh you know you can watch them
on Facebook the free portion so that's
what we do with mug Club the there's
about 45 minutes I think with Nick it's
about 35 minutes yeah and then you get
the extended the stuff that we could
never say on any platform Rumble
probably would allow it but even then it
shouldn't be seen by everybody so uh you
can still go uncensored can you imagine
yeah I know Alex Jones uncensored oh
Lord so you can you can go and watch
their free portion but none of this
happens there is no free content
wherever you're watching Rumble uh or
YouTube without mug club letterscore.com
we appreciate it Brian Cowan September
23rd is going to be in Melbourne Florida
that's right my friend the unreasonable
tour go to Brian callan.com you just
made that up right now it is not labeled
that yet he was in the he's like I
should call it unreasonable I'm like
well fine we don't have the graphic for
it I wrote it down I wrote it down in
your Notepad is going to be chat
Thursday you can click right there as
you just saw that graphic to join mug
Club we're about to take a bunch of your
chats and you know what that's always a
lot of fun and of course we'll see you
tomorrow Alex Jones tomorrow Rumble
thank you very much YouTube piss off
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]